une production du studio SF
iltre le podcasts
[Musique]
maintenant vous êtes probablement déjà
sur la Lune
merci le progrès
[Rires]
la semaine prochaine
on a décidé de faire comme à toutes les
années un best of de nos performances
honnêtement les performances du musée de
[Musique]
un petit peu moins de podcast en terme
de nombre mais honnêtement quand on
regardait la liste pour faire justement
une pour choisir lesquels on voulait
garder
j'étais toute des toutes des vraiment
des belles conversations on était choyé
au niveau des invités cette année sur le
sans fil d'ailleurs merci vous invitez
leur temps premièrement leur
connaissance leurs expériences
leurs talent c'est
grâce à vous qu'on existe qu'on est là
grâce à vous aussi grâce à vous le
public merci beaucoup public du sans fil
podcast le meilleur public on l'a déjà
dit encore
on va aller sur cette discussion entre
nous sur les podcasts marquants de 2023
bon podcast bonne écoute
le podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
melscape et comment ne pas mieux
terminer l'année 2022 et commencer
l'année 2023 avec nous plus fidèles nos
plus nos plus nos plus chers à notre
cœur commentaire
oh c'est quoi ce sang c'est la chandeuse
4.0 dans mes oreilles ça je me mets ça
pour m'endormir le soir en fait ça
me relax moi je suis je suis rendu là ma
barbe en ce moment c'est ma barbe
blanche une barbe c'est le plus long que
pas mal le plus long que j'ai eu dans ma
vie là j'ai rarement plus long que ça
puis je t'avais du passé
dur là mais semaine vous pouvez le faire
[Rires]
moi mon gros gros coup de cœur c'est les
deux produits ici le shampoing et
conditionneur 2 en 1 et le body wash
avec l'odeur caractéristique de man's
skate sors de la douche tu sens bon sans
frais je me fais complimenter sur mon
odeur sur une base certains diraient
hebdomadaire hebdomadaire à peu près ce
qui est quand même très raisonnable donc
parfum c'est plus souvent le parfum
refine de manscape c'est plus souvent
que ça mais quand je fais juste me laver
les cheveux et me laver le body wash
hebdomadaire puis je vois pas beaucoup
de monde
[Musique]
mais les produits mannequins sont
absolument incroyables c'est le parfait
cadeau c'est le parfait cadeau pour
démontrer votre affection
on a un code promo pour vous qui est
absolument légendaire rendu là il est
légendaire
sans filtre 20% de rabais livraison
gratuite c'est énorme comme rabais
profiter de ça et assurez-vous que promo
sans filtre pour vous leur montrer que
vous écoutez le sans filtre ça nous aide
beaucoup c'est du sport pour le show
c'est du sport pour ne pas pour tout le
monde pour qu'on continue à faire cette
belle aventure que ça fait le podcast
encore une autre année c'est n'est que
le début merci
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par cosy cosy c'est honnêtement ma
révélation de l'année où il y a
peut-être vu passer sur Internet CD sofa
qui viennent chez vous dans des boîtes
séparées et qui s'assemble sans outil
comme des Lego comme des gros blocs Lego
honnêtement
je te l'ai dit la dernière fois que je
t'ai parlé de Cosy on a parlé un petit
peu notre déménagement horrible qu'on a
vu qu'on a vécu ensemble la dernière
fois quand les boîtes de causes sont
arrivées chez nous ça a été super facile
à monter jusque au deuxième étage chez
nous j'ai ouvert les bois j'ai assemblé
ça ça m'a pris une heure maximum pour
tout assembler au complet pour un bon
divan un bon sofa un bon sur trois
places avec un petit sofa une place à
côté avec un pouf pour mettre les pieds
puis j'ai pas honte de le dire c'est le
meilleur chauffeur dans lequel je me
suis assis je pense beaucoup de temps
écoutez le football le dimanche
elle aussi à tripes sur mon divan cosy
puis je te dis même ça nous a rapproché
ça nous a rapproche ça gratte grâce au
cosy les fesses rentrent dans le divan
c'est vraiment confortable il est à la
bonne hauteur puis quand on va être le
temps de le déplacer je peux facilement
le déplacer parce que ça se défait sans
outil c'est incroyable honnêtement c'est
incroyable je te le dis je prends
vraiment la plupart avec qui on
travaille je les aime vraiment causer je
les adore
rectum cherche une maison bientôt demain
matin
tu verras pour vrai parce que c'est
ultra simple super efficace puis surface
sont débiles allez au saut au sauf aller
au cosy.ca pour voir toute la puis vous
pouvez aussi faire la dimension que vous
voulez la forme que vous voulez il y a
plein d'options des années quasiment sur
mesure tu peux le voir dans l'espace tu
peux voir quelqu'un d'une grandeur de
515 mettons que s'asseoir dedans pour
voir comment toi tu aurais l'air c'était
à 111 dedans tu peux tout faire ça sur
le site cosy.ca allez voir ça c'est
absolument incroyable d'abord merci
cousine merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue à tous bonne année bonne année
bonne année bon début d'année 2023
j'espère que vous avez passé un bon
temps des fêtes vous avez profité que
vous allez manger vous avez bu vous avez
la famille
c'est important
donc je voulais te féliciter pour ça
fait deux fois que je cours en écoutant
ta playlist 66 chansons 66 bonnes
chansons 2022 2022 pourquoi ça sent
du docteur
ils vont au moins avoir une coupe de
bannière mettons des trucs plus mais en
fait pourquoi j'ai mis dans l'ordre
parce que je les ai mis comme du plus
soft au plus intense mais donc
c'est pour ça
d'écoute que je fais mais c'est quand
même ça c'est pas mal la plus complet
c'est 6h je pense que dure mais oui
c'est de la musique qui est relaxe
mais ouais c'est ça c'est parce que tu
mettes
sur le même dame puis là tu passes déjà
de quoi crissement Mollo à genre une
tonne de punk rock à Beyoncé genre
un milieu d'après-midi quand il tombe ce
livre
le plus ça va plus la soirée avance puis
la musique devient plus en plus intense
et à la fin de la soirée déjà debout sur
Terre
en ce moment finissez le sans fil que
vous écoutez maintenant puis après ça
garde votre voyage de chance sera pas
fini encore aller écouter les 66 tonnes
les 66 Boston de 2022
qui ont pas de chanson puis à celle-là
quand tu cherches Dominique plein de
choses
tu peux aller faire ma recherche tantôt
je pourrais le checker
je suis tombé aussi sur ta playlist
partez
c'est juste les listes de lecture
ok non c'est ça c'est zéro like y'a
quand même parti soirée 2022 puis les
chambres rouges 2 mais ce que ça je fais
ça pour moi dans le sens que j'oublie
que les gens peuvent avoir accès parce
que mettons les chambres rouges c'est le
fait ma Pascal exigeant admettons il me
fait tout le temps des playlist
inspiration de clics
et j'ai écouté telle affaire Chris mon
épouse ok c'est ça le monde pourrait
trouver si ça pourrait être intéressant
pour les gens qui nous écoutent vous
savez que c'est on a on a produit
réalisé le podcast de True Crime post
mortem avec Peter Charlton on en a déjà
parlé sur sur le dernier qui est né mais
si ça vous intéresse si vous avez aimé
l'ambiance sonore si vous allez dans le
profil de Dominique plante sur spa de
faire vous pouvez trouver la playlist
True Crime Victoria où est-ce que vous
allez trouver les inspirations pour ça
c'est normal
[Rires]
podcast qu'on a fait nous ce qu'on a
jugé les plus les plus funks
ce que tu veux
c'est ça notre décision un peu de forme
on va réduire un peu la quantité pour
augmenter la qualité ou du moins
consommer la question
à choisir j'avais comme une chute de
plusieurs noms puis on se dit comme
trône que ça peut être facile ouais
effectivement tu veux tu y aller avec
ton ta première nomination je peux y
aller ma première animation les noms
avec laquelle je commence je vais
commencer avec Benoît oui peignoir ça
non je trouve que je trouve que c'est
dans l'étape ouais parce que ça a été un
peu la culmination d'un long processus
de long cheminement où est-ce qu'on a
parlé d'un sujet sur un sujet quand on
parlait de santé puis de poids on a
parlé plusieurs invités puis comme on
disait avec Benoît c'est un sujet qui
est chez vous on a parlé
il y avait des réactions il y avait des
commentaires il y avait des gens qui
étaient pas d'accord avec soi nous avec
son être invité ça crée des débats que
tentatives de d'annulation du sans fil
podcast
il y a certains commentaires qui ont
passé le sur des pages plus à plongeur
radical de de l'Instagram avec des
stations provenant du sans filtre disons
qu'on était problématique par nos propos
mais il y a rien de nouveau sur le
soleil
donc un sujet chaud quand même mais qui
nous intéressait tous les deux parce que
c'est la santé essentiellement qui nous
intéresse dans ce sujet-là tu sais puis
après ça c'est comment est-ce qu'on
l'aborde c'était ça la question mais oui
pitié je veux dire depuis longtemps le
monde font une association avec le poids
la santé je veux dire dans l'esprit du
monde aussi bien d'en parler puis de
voir qu'est-ce qui si de quoi elle en
retour
une vérité là-dedans ou non
parce que le podcast avec Benoît il y a
pas mal mis le clou
cette conversation là parce que lui
c'est un expert dans le domaine il y a
une approche basée sur la science exacte
c'était pas mal ça qui nous manquait un
peu dans l'avantage des des
invités qu'on a reçu pour parler de ça
c'était vraiment la proche scientifique
de santé santé cardiovasculaire
principalement factice je pense que le
podcast on va mettre un extrait un petit
peu plus tard mais je pense que le
podcast au complet il vaut la peine
d'être écouté pour avoir juste là-dessus
moi je trouve je l'ai écouté un peu
tantôt et puis
podcast on parle des l'IMC une famille
IMC
pourquoi que l'IMC c'est pas une valeur
une mesure fiable pour mesurer l'état de
la santé d'une personne
puis là il y a plein de variables
grandes il y a le sexe premièrement de
la personne les mêmes
de où tu viens dans le monde et ça ça
change puis
est-ce que je trouvais vraiment
intéressant en fait c'est quand qu'il
nous a dit c'était quoi la mesure qui
était selon lui la plus fiable mettons
pour prédire la mortalité chez quelqu'un
ça mesure le c'est
la VO2max les capacités
cardio-respiratoires cardiovasculaires
qu'au final qui est pas mal
communément appelé le cardio mettons
globalement
donc la genre de forme le physique
essentiellement
avoir un poids ben je dirais répondance
de beauté puis c'est même pas le seul
dont on parle puis ce sera pas
nécessairement indicateur de santé ou
non tu peux quand même avoir cet
accord-là et puis complètement
aboutissant versus versus
à être abonné MC plus grand bien en
forme
de ramener ça puis après ça justement
ce qui explique aussi dans le podcast
c'est que il y a une grosse partie
génétique à ce qu'il y a des gens qui
font jamais rien de leur vie qui vont
être fucking en forme tout le temps il y
a des gens qui qui font toute qui
marchent comme il faut puis qu'ils ont
juste une génétique
juste la vie mais il y a aussi la partie
qu'on peut contrôler qui est avoir des
bonnes habitudes de vie c'est sûr que la
même personne avec bonne attitude de vie
et moi et puis il va être mieux c'est
ceux qui vont être mieux c'est sûr qu'il
va avoir une santé cardiovasculaire
meilleur max puis une meilleure
espérance de vie finalement bref
excellent premier choix tout à fait ça
commence au début de l'année là en plus
moi c'est ça c'est ça
je reçois des messages déjà dans mon
cours de nutrition dans mon cours de si
de ça on a écouté
un excellent follow sur Instagram
et partage parfois des activités qui
fait dans nature mais partage souvent
des
études qui sortent de nouvelles études
qui viennent montrer des nouvelles
affaires principalement par rapport à la
coloration de poissons
[Musique]
juste ton tour de taille mettons souvent
c'est la graisse abdominale qui est
comme problématique genre sous les abdos
de taille est une donnée plus accueil
mais bon pour prédire ton état de santé
que même si c'est pas parfaitement
puis de minceur perd du poids souvent on
voit cette équation là comme étant
simplifiée au plus bas possible pour
perdre du poids faut que tu es un genre
à moins de calories tu en dépense qu'en
est-il ben c'est vrai le tu sais ça
c'est une des premières lois de la
thermodynamique rien ne se perd rien
si tu es capable de de
maintenir un déficit calorique à long
terme la plupart des gens vont perdre du
poids bon peut-être pas la plupart c'est
passé difficile de pas vraiment d'études
qui ont été faites là-dessus donc il y a
des gens qui vont perdre du poids il y a
des gens qui en perdront pas
nécessairement puissant encore une fois
il y a une grosse composante génétique à
savoir dans un situation de restriction
calorique qui va perdre du poids puis
qui n'en perdra pas puis là tu sais j'ai
des travaux en tête de d'un chercheur
même de l'Université Laval qui s'appelle
Claude Bouchard qui a fait ça eux ce qui
en fait c'est qu'ils ont pris des
jumeaux puis ils ont pas mis sur une
attestation calorique mais ils ont mis
dans un dans un excès de de calories
donc des jumeaux de la
restrictions là c'est comment pile ou
face il y en a un qui va dans un excès
l'autre restriction
mais mais finalement on pense que on
pense que c'est facile de détente en
surplus énergétique c'est plus
challengeant qu'on pense là justement
lui ce qui avait fait c'est qu'il y
avait pris des bases c'était pas une
équipe à l'Université Laval qui avait
mis des jumeaux en surplus calorique
pendant 100 jours puis donc là c'est ce
qu'il faut avec ce type d'étude là c'est
que ben c'est tantôt je vous disais que
les les jeunes de l'obésité souvent il
était exprimé dans le cerveau mais là
c'est que c'est que la puissance
influence notre prise alimentaire mais
dans cette étude là c'est comme si on
avait tassé le cerveau parce qu'on
nourrissait on nourrissait les gens on
leur disait aujourd'hui bah toi par
rapport à
tes besoins énergétiques bah il faut que
tu manges pour dire quelque chose 3000
calories donc on va te donner 3000
calories aujourd'hui effectivement ton
cerveau qui décide du nombre de calories
puis là même à ça évidemment la plupart
des des jumeaux parce qu'il était
justement en surplus énergétique ben la
plupart ont pris du poids mais encore
une fois il y en a qui ont pris 2 kg il
y en a qui ont pris
si le premier jumeau avait pris deux
kilos l'autre en avait pris deux ici
dans un autre site de jumeaux il y en a
un qui avait pris 10 kg l'autre en avait
pris 10 aussi ça ça a été fait aussi au
niveau de la restriction calorique donc
au lieu de faire un surplus énergétique
on fait une restriction calorique
corrélation parfaite avec une
restriction calorique autant faite par
l'alimentation que par l'activité
physique parce que on peut jouer sur la
balance énergétique en diminuant la peur
mais aussi en augmentant la dépense
énergétique dans les deux cas les
résultats étaient étaient sans équivoque
dans le sens que
on perdait du poids qu'en été en balance
énergétique négative mais il y avait une
variabilité inter-individuelle qui était
vraiment impressionnante
on est de retour on est de retour moi
mon premier nommé c'est Mathieu
Blanchard le podcast Mathieu Blanchard
parce que Mathieu Blanchard au moment où
est-ce qu'on l'a reçu au Québec qui
n'était pas encore extrêmement connu il
venait d'avoir une performance
extraordinaire au
Ultra Trail du Mont Blanc en arrivant
troisième puis j'ai choisi ce podcast là
parce que premièrement c'est un idole
Stéphane absolument un réel femme de sa
carrière de coureurs de trail les choses
qui a fait les les
aventures même au-delà de sa garde
d'aventurier aussi je suis vraiment si
vous aimez si vous voulez suivre
quelqu'un sur Instagram on parlait
tantôt
incroyable sur Instagram et il
s'aventurent tout le temps les affaires
débiles mais ce qui nous avait dit
après sa performance de troisième
position sur l'UTMB qui est le Superbowl
des ultra trails vous avez dit je sais
pas s'il avait dit un nom ou or on qui
avait compris quelque chose pour l'ultra
trail du Mont-Blanc qui s'envenait puis
une chose qui s'est passé après ça c'est
que Mathieu après venu à notre podcast
probablement sans incidence avec sa
présence à notre podcast et lancer
lui-même son propre podcast qui
s'appelle dans mon bain puis c'était
vraiment le récit bi hebdomadaire non
bimensuel deux fois par mois bimensuel
c'est deux fois par mois une fois deux
mois
[Musique]
deux fois par mois une fois à chaque
deux semaines il y avait un paquet qui
sortait qui racontait toutes ces étapes
préparatoires soit son entraînement à
son alimentation ça récupération et il
nous a amené avec lui dans les courses
de préparation qui faisaient vers
culminer avec sa présence au ultra du
Mont-Blanc de cette année qui vient
depuis le lieu depuis son podcast où
est-ce que là il y a couru la course de
sa vie il a réussi à passer sous la
barre des 20h que d'une barre mythique
qui avait jamais été faite sur le
parcours de l'UTMB est arrivé deuxième
derrière le plus grand coureur de trail
de tous les temps qu'il y a une journée
après cette battue avec pendant toute la
nuit puis toute la matinée avant
d'arriver à Chamonix seulement 5 minutes
derrière lui les genoux grande foulées
dans la foule c'était je pleure souvent
en regardant le sport parce que c'est je
trouve ça c'est des histoires qui
s'écrivent d'elle-même mais je trouvais
ça d'autant plus débile que pas
un an avant la version sur le Podcast
puis
nous avez il nous avait expliqué son
parcours nous avait parlé du fait qu'il
y avait compris quelque chose clairement
il y a compris quelque chose c'est
quelque chose là il est évidemment pas
dévoilé mais genre de parler pour pour
essayer de demander c'était quoi
finalement ça va faire là que tu as
compris
une théorie sur qu'est-ce qui aurait pu
comprendre ouais j'ai une théorie j'ai
une théorie l'année où est-ce que tu es
arrivé troisième
il y a mentionné qui allait qui attaquer
le parcours selon des temps de passage
au ravitaillement basé sur les temps de
passage du record fait qu'il voyait le
record mais si je me tiens à peu près à
tant de temps du record je vais être
capable de bien gérer ma course puis de
finir plus fort que les autres ils vont
partir trop vite c'est ce qui a fait
pour arriver troisième mais cette année
il y aura juste une variable à ça
c'était
je vais mettre mon métal passage sauf
que au-delà des temps de passage je vais
avoir une valeur qui va être supérieure
ça va être ne jamais être tant j'ai mis
des temps aussi de distance maximale
envers la taille de la course ok à
chaque ravitaillement fait que ça
faisait que si mettons le temps de
passage j'étais trop lent
il tombait sur l'autre option qui était
au Québec il faut que tu sois sûr le
temps de distance envers la taille de la
course ce qui a fait que il s'est mis
moins dans un trou il y a quand même
fini vraiment fort pour réussir à finir
deuxième cette fois-là fait que je pense
que
je vais demander la prochaine fois je le
vois mais ma théorie ce serait que il
s'est mis une autre valeur que je vous
ai temps de passage faisant alors là
c'était la distance entre lui et la
taille de la course parce que même si il
fait un bon temps si les autres font
encore meilleur temps mais je les ai
quand même exactement
trou sachant que tu finis fort les
courses puis lui c'est lui c'est un gars
qui
qui n'est pas faite comme toi puis moi
c'est après
70 km avec 10000 m de dénivelé plus du
du
UTMB course de 19h58
le lendemain de ça il reprend son
téléphone pour faire la dernière épisode
dans mon bain et puis il fait moi je
suis pas raqué le lendemain de course
alors que du monde qui rentre de sortir
de leur chambre d'hôtel lui et que
le lendemain d'un 170 km avec 10000 m de
dénivelé positif fait quelque chose qui
se passe là quand même qui se passe pas
avec la majorité des gens
ça c'est quand même assez incroyable
puis l'autre affaire qui avait parlé
dans le podcast que j'avais trouvé
vraiment hot c'était
quand qu'il y avait juste comme un peu
fait planer l'utopie d'un monde où
est-ce que le monde se déplace en
courant puis là ma blonde actuellement à
court partout ce qu'elle va cours à
l'hôpital à court à va travailler en
courant parvient en course à fait genre
20 km par jour mais au final
c'est quasiment pas temps plus long à
court mais non
12 minutes
genre c'est l'oeil du Québec c'est
l'espèce de gros rond le gros réservoir
en rond en rôle ce qui a fait c'est qui
est allé là avec un autre gars puis en
fait le tour de tout ça en genre de ski
de ce qu'ils font genre en traînant
toute leur stocks le tour de ça et on
dormit là-dedans à moins 40 dans les
sacs de il y avait des vidéos là un sac
de couchage qui a tellement de
condensation autour de ça que je l'ai
mais c'est des sacs de couchage fait
pour ça
il sort de la tente il faut juste la
glace case il reste sec
des vidéos il se réveillaient de même en
glacé le genre glacé de la tête aux
pieds c'est fou c'est débile c'est genre
du jour je pense ça tu sais toujours je
fais une parenthèse là j'ai écouté
l'autre jour même je tombais dans un
vortex de YouTube j'écoutais
documentaires sur la vie dans le village
le plus froid au monde c'est genre dans
le Nord d'autochtones
je sais pas
non mais je pense que je pense que c'est
aussi le peuple Inuit je crois mais là
mais c'est comme c'est sur le village
habitait à l'année le plus froid qui
fait le plus froid que genre le record
qui était je pense c'est moins 70 le
plus froid qui a été enregistré là-bas
[Musique]
en plus ils vivent pas une vie comme
étant dans des genres de maisons isolées
à fond comme nous autres
ils font beaucoup de travail à
l'extérieur puis genre il faut qu'il
pêcher les autres même leur poisson puis
genre il faut qu'il leur toilette à
l'extérieur
c'est fou le genre tu peux ils peuvent
quasiment rien faire pousser à part
genre une petite mini fenêtre dans l'été
peut-être
je suis connecté à toutes les chaînes
des podcasts
habituellement je suis genre sur
upica podcast le genre c'est sur ce que
je check les affaires qui m'intéressent
mais quand met-on change pour une pour
une raison X puis je vois sur le
homepage on dirait que c'est un autre
site Web complètement c'est fou
les vidéos de musique des vidéos de Star
Wars c'est ça exactement
à penser que c'est ça
tout le monde tout le monde écoute
tellement l'affaire bref on va écouter
une extrait Mathieu Blanchard extrait
et donc avec le temps et l'expérience
ton rapport à la douleur
physique et mentale et énergétique va
évoluer ou ça va devenir sur une échelle
de 5 sur 10 un 8 sur 10 douloureux au
bout de quelques années va devenir un 3
sur 10 tu vois et c'est c'est que pour
moi
grandi aujourd'hui dans dans des
sociétés tellement
protégé avec beaucoup d'hygiène autour
de nous qui fait que quand on est enfant
on tombe pas on se casse pas c'est la
gueule par terre et puis en finit par
voilà découvrir des vrais douleurs un
peu quand on se met dans des sports
comme ça assez tard dans la vie quand on
se pousse et puis on n'est pas on sait
pas accoutumé à ça dans notre jeunesse
mais en tout cas moi c'est mon
expérience aujourd'hui là et puis c'est
mon expérience là c'est pas forcément
valider scientifiquement ce que je vais
dire mais j'ai l'impression que mon
rapport à la douleur évolue avec le
temps donc c'est ça pour répondre à ta
question lorsque je veux je vais être
dans un DA on est dans une course une
douleur il y a que la blessure qui va
m'arrêter au final c'est une vraie
blessure c'est à dire une jambe péter là
je vais m'arrêter mais si c'est une
crampe une tension dans un muscle ma
tête qui veut plus une envie de vomir
c'est pas suffisant pour me faire
arrêter et avec l'expérience j'ai appris
que que voilà
c'est la logique voudrait que ça soit
une courbe qui partent d'un certain
niveau d'énergie et peu de douleur de la
ligne de départ jusqu'à la ligne
d'arrivée ça va être juste au cours
descendante descendant descendant
descendante jusqu'aux en enfers mais
alors en fait c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout ça c'est hyper magique et
puis c'est
incompréhensible pour moi ça va être
plutôt une sinusoïde tu comprends pas
pourquoi tout d'un coup elle a 8e heure
de la 8e à la dixième heure ça va pas du
tout tu as envie de vomir tu as mal
partout et tout d'un coup à la dixième
heure parce qu'il se passe ça va bien tu
as plus aucune douleur tu as un niveau
d'énergie de dingue et tout et puis
c'est c'est ça donc on est de retour on
est de retour de cette extrait avec
Mathieu Blanchard j'ai envie d'écouter
incroyable je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on a
choisi mais c'est incroyable
sinon moi un de mes podcast coup de
coeur
on s'enfiltre on fait souvent des
podcasts politiques ou des podcasts
qui traite de sujets d'actualité de soit
de conflits internationaux ou de ou de
politique en général puis là un écouteur
c'est le podcast qu'on a fait avec Annie
qui nous a parlé du conflit en fait du
conflit des manifestations en Iran qui
ont lieu et qui ont toujours lieu en
fait au jour on se parle puis
je trouve que extrêmement
que son sujet tout à fait puis c'était
le rêve le paradis des invités quoi
ouais vraiment c'est le genre de podcast
qui est en fait j'allais dire qui est
facile qui vraiment difficile le sujet
est difficile mais qui est tellement
facile à amener pour nous deux alors
qu'on fait juste comme être curieux puis
s'intéresser puis la personne devant
nous que toutes les connaissances pour
nous nous éduquer en fait c'est ça c'est
ça l'objectif c'est puis
le fait que tu as aussi à Tout le monde
en parle la veille qu'on la reçoivent
comme un hasard on avait bouqué ça ça
faisait un petit bout déjà non c'était
vraiment
c'est un super rencontre moi j'ai
ressorti de ça en comprenant mais oui
c'est ça le conflit tu sais en
comprenant le conflit non seulement en
croyant le conflit actuel mais aussi
comprenant c'est en fait c'est
impossible de comprendre réellement le
conflit ce qu'on prend pas de contexte
auto puis historique de la partie de
l'endroit où on parle et puis en Iran et
en histoire vraiment particulière
justement c'est ce que je c'est tantôt
un peu en préparant puis
c'est un pays qui a jadis était super
moderne et ouvert puis vraiment pas un
état religieux qui m'a été aujourd'hui
sous une dictature qui comme un peu sous
un roi le chat ce qui est un peu
paradoxal contradictoire dans notre
esprit mais lui il était super genre il
te faut l'inspiré par l'Occident Go
modernité les femmes pouvaient
travailler les femmes faut avoir des
postes importants puis les voiles t'es
pas obligatoire puis les sont dit on est
amené
de la monarchie on met ça dehors on fait
une révolution finalement la révolution
c'est comme si on a changé quatre
transitions pour
deux dizaines deux scènes vraiment pire
mais finalement ça sent vraiment pire
intéressant de comprendre exactement
comment ça ça s'est fait comment se
payer là c'est quand même métamorphosé
pour devenir ce qui est aujourd'hui puis
c'est absolument rien
les années 70
sur ça pour finir là-dessus
est-ce que tu voulais dire c'est que tu
regardais encore aujourd'hui
comme quand on avait parlé de l'Ukraine
justement c'était comme nouveau
peut-être combien de temps ça va durer
puis on dirait que les conflit il se
règle pas puis nous on arrête d'en
parler parce qu'elle m'a amené comme un
épuisement puis c'est normal si on peut
pas juste comme durer à l'infini mais on
parle avec autant d'autant d'implication
parce que ça devient insoutenable même
si on sait que c'est encore plus
invivable de vivre ces conflits-là que
de juste être dans un petit confort
personnel puis de regarder le Bye Bye
puis de faire mais c'est quand même
c'est du stock quand tu penses à ça puis
c'est juste
j'avais cette pensée là plus peut-être
pas nécessairement en lien avec avec
l'Iran puis ce podcast là mais
s'il y a des familles qui ont perdu
l'électricité pour Noël puis
4 quand tu fais genre
l'électricité du monde en Ukraine qui
qui ont pas d'exister sur un an puis
c'est ça leur ville genre il faut pas
plus chaud qu'ici non pas mieux c'est
pas plus confortable dans un sous-sol à
briller sans électricité dans une ville
c'est bombarder genre ici on est quand
même on peut pas fêter Noël chez Manon
c'est poche
mais non mais c'est ça mais de temps en
temps un petit électrochoc de juste en
perspective
notre frigo qui remplit d'opulence de
bof qu'on va remplir quand le savoir
partir tu sais genre c'est pas là c'est
du gaspillé alimentaire c'est la merde
mais genre moi je veux dire la chose la
plus privilégiée la plus dégueu
aujourd'hui mais mettons à Hawaï Hill en
voyage qu'on a fait une semaine de
Vannes donc de camping
la plupart des campings qu'on était
[Musique]
juste d'avoir des privés on avait pas de
toilette dans mon on avait pas de
dos on avait dit on avait tout en
camping
puis bref mais juste quand tu te fais
enlever quelque chose que tu es habitué
d'avoir apporté une main tout le temps
c'est tellement facile avoir de l'eau
ici genre
[Musique]
tout ce que ça prend
pour que ce soit face à tourner un truc
qui sort comme par magie mais genre
c'est pas de la magie non c'est fou tout
ce que il a fallu l'électrique même
chose l'électricité encore payé mais non
on envoie ça genre du Nord et si dans
des films jusqu'ici dans toutes les
maisons du Monde du débile pour tout
genre même chose
puis mais c'est ça mais le perte de
temps en temps puis là moi je te parle
moi j'étais quand même je veux dire dans
le spectre du grand confort de la ville
de sa plage
paradisiaque
je suis pas du temps en train de me
plaindre mais juste c'est
ça pour dire que perdre quelque chose
c'est un reminder qui est comme c'est
pas tout qui supposé être aussi facile
tout le temps d'en vivre et que ça remet
une chose en perspective puis
puis
encore un main deux qui est des gens qui
vivent des situations un million de fois
pire
des podcasts comme ça ça
c'est un petit réalité tchèque aussi
mais ouais bref ça la situation c'est
encore des des gens qui sont tirés dans
la rue des gens qui sont exécutés des il
y avait une actrice iranienne connue qui
était emprisonné que lui qui vient
d'être lâché c'est parce que je pense il
y avait trop de pression internationales
c'est que elle avait pris position en
faveur de manifestations emprisonné même
parlant trois semaines c'est fou l'un tu
sais c'est comme c'est quelqu'un encore
une fois mais bon en question
perspective quand des fois on a
l'impression qu'il si on vit sur une un
régime totalitaire c'est pas le même
niveau là non c'est pas la même chose
est-ce qu'on peut appeler ça une guerre
civile en ce moment ce qui se passe en
Iran pour être honnête avec vous je ne
sais pas comment on l'appelle
tantôt certaines personnes vont dire on
est plus dans dans une demande de
réforme on n'est plus dans une révolte
on est dans une révolution c'est vrai
que certains personnes peuvent parler de
de guerre civile moi je parlerai en
termes de rupture moi je pense qu'il y a
une rupture
visible physique sans équivoque d'une
rupture réelle entre la société et
l'État aujourd'hui le message est clair
on veut plus de la République islamique
d'Iran on veut plus celle si vous voulez
c'est la c'est la confrontation de deux
mondes vous avez d'un côté un monde qui
prône et qui veut en fait gouverner
comme une société islamique et vous avez
une autre société qui a des aspirations
démocratiques et qui a une vie qui en
tout cas défend l'humanisme et des fois
en tout cas des valeurs ou des libertés
les plus les plus fondamentales c'est le
droit de circuler le droit de presse le
droit la liberté de presse la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'opinion la
liberté d'exister je pense tout
simplement en tant qu'individu à le
premier sens du mot liberté c'est une
possibilité de choix c'est exactement ce
que la population iranienne n'a pas
les jeunes n'ont pas les femmes n'ont
pas les hommes non plus et c'est
intéressant de parler aussi des hommes
dans cette société parce que je pense
aussi que c'est un des premiers pays au
Moyen-Orient dans un état islamique où
on a vu que les hommes étaient aux côtés
des femmes et quand les femmes sortent
aujourd'hui dans la rue son voile
aujourd'hui maintenant les femmes c'est
devenu une résistance on va ne plus
porter le voile et c'est extraordinaire
il y a des messages qui sortirent sur
les réseaux sociaux il y a une jeune
femme qui dit mais moi de mon travail
jusqu'à ma voiture j'ai pas porté le
voile c'est une révolution dans le sens
où c'est des peut-être des petits pas
c'est un grand page je pense parce que
en fait
allez j'ai envie de dire s'il y a bien
une révolution dans ce pays pour moi
c'est une révolution sexuelle et c'est
une révolution culturelle et ça ça en
vous toutes les autres évolutions
en fait je pense que c'est un des
podcasts mémorables
c'est de loin le podcast duquel on a le
plus parlé de l'année 2022 de loin dans
mes DM quand je croisais les personnes
puis moi quand on est sorti de ce
podcast là on butait on boit plus
vraiment d'alcool dans le sans fil
podcast genre on est on le faisait déjà
pas avant on le fait plus vraiment puis
nicole est venu ici pour nous dire
Nicole tu nous disais que tu Nicki il va
pas il va peut-être intervenir le mec
Nicole qui est rentré dans le studio
pour nous expliquer qui trouvait plus
son anus déjà qui était pas capable de
trouver son anus à faire en sortant
Nicole je pense que tu es là
ça a été le truc que je me suis fait le
plus parler dans dernière année je me
faisais aborder par des inconnus pour me
faire parler de ça c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable
Nicole il vient là j'ai plus de Mike là
en sortant chaque homme genre qu'est-ce
qui commence à voir comment ça va sortir
en même temps on a eu du fun que genre
je m'en colle ça un peu au début du
podcast les trois tu sais les trous vous
êtes en même temps puisqu'on contient
des histoires puis genre déjà
c'était de raconter
pour moi puis pour la montre qui écoute
fou genre expliquer le genre vous êtes
les trois
craquer que vous êtes juste un boys vous
prenez une bière
je comprends rien mais c'est ça mais
finalement ça comme vraiment raisonné
genre on dirait que le monde ont comme
vraiment embarqué son genre comme ça
justement c'est c'était comme comme
platine vous avez dit amener le decom
Aymen c'est j'avais l'impression d'être
dans votre soirée de gars quand vous
faites juste parler comme vous le
faisiez là genre puis il y a plein de
monde qui m'a écrit j'ai l'impression
d'être assez à côté de la table avec
vous autres riais comme des cotes dans
mon short seule
les deux les deux sont vraiment bons
pour
vider de l'énergie des autres
Sandrine quand
la tension
il devient même Fred pèlerin à compter
des histoires mais c'est ça puis il fait
pas genre il fait pas jouer la tension
du monde c'est juste qu'on dirait qu'il
se nourrit à ça tellement puis là je te
dis même il devient un compteur les gens
derrière le pied Adamo il y a d'amour
fait quelqu'un qui raconte une histoire
Adamo c'est genre la chose la plus
loufoque une scène les figures de style
les plus débiles tout le temps Adamo
naturel comique même comme il y en a
Rome je veux dire
le monde c'est débile talent incroyable
mais tu sais juste à amené il dit puis
on pourra mettre cet extrait là si
jamais Nicole tu ressors trouver le bois
tu vois ce qu'il y a d'amour il raconte
il explique
à place de dire un coup d'épée dans
l'eau il dit que c'est comme quand tu
t'installes demain puis deux pieds
par-dessus le bord du bas
sans toucher rien d'autre qui est
agréable
un coup d'épée dans l'eau
c'est comme une longue une longue image
puis là on l'écoutait plus c'était comme
tout ça pour ça même c'est ça pour cette
image là
ça comme ça ça marche pas
mais oui ça m'a l'arabe
tout le temps en fait tu sors d'affaires
ça tout le temps était un peu à une
directrice qui en a pas vraiment puis
genre mais ça faisait longtemps quand
même pitié peut-être naturellement on
fait de plus en plus des sujets un peu
plus sérieux
la rigolade des moins au rendez-vous
tout le temps mais là comme fait du bien
déjà faire tout un podcast où est-ce
qu'il y a comme on a notre phone qui
décide puis de mon émission on pourrait
en 2023 c'est dire qu'on refait un peu
plus de podcast avec des amis juste pour
chellé on peut ramener la rigolade
je pense ça pourrait être bénéfique il y
en a à toutes les années des bas de gaz
demain un peu le mais il y en a pas
c'est vrai qu'il y en a moins genre
d'habitude il y en avait peut-être deux
trois par année à peu près c'est tout à
fait raison de soi j'en prends une
petite bière en même temps là
à faire aussi
mais oui
on va ramener ça fait qu'on va aller
écouter on va essayer de trouver une
colle sur le trouble tu trouves pas
c'est parfait du monde là mais l'extrait
de Adamo qui explique un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
j'assiais genre c'est comme si je me
mettais je remplis
mon bain je me mets là en position
pochette alentours là j'essaie de me
faire venir en fourant l'eau
c'est ça c'est là que tu t'en allais
même avec ton image même genre quand tu
parlais de ton bain et mon gars je
pensais que tu allais aller à un million
de places
faut que je finisse laisse-moi finir mon
idée laisse-moi dans mon processus
créatif
on est de retour
salut le bon vieux un amour
les bonbons moi mes podcast
là aussi favori de l'année c'est le
podcast avec Adil
c'est tout le temps dis-moi je veux dire
on se voit on se voit plus maintenant
lorsqu'on travaille ensemble aussi sur
la musique puis
il y a du monde que
ces personnes là comme
grandit grandit
tout le temps tu apprends quelque chose
ben genre tu réfléchis tu vois quelque
chose un nouvel angle de mettons
une capacité de comme de perspective des
trucs puis de réflexion comme
c'est assez rare
c'est un super orateur puis
des fois il est pas là
[Musique]
sur le coup mettons je soupçonne pas ça
mais que il y a des phrases qui me reste
des concepts qui me restent auquel je
reparle puis que probablement qui
influence un peu
la personne que je suis comment j'agis
dans la vie puis mettons dans ce podcast
là il y avait il y a eu ce qui à chaque
fois qu'on a reçu à dire il y a ça parce
que la fois d'avant aussi il y avait des
trucs qui m'intéressaient puis je
ramenais souvent puis moi c'est le
passage à ce qu'on parle des
divisions dans la vie dans la société il
y en a beaucoup
de plus en plus de plus en plus et puis
division que ça soit gauche droite
Provac scientifique ou toutes les
divisions possibles on dirait qu'on est
un peu à l'air d'être ça
ça t'appartient à tel groupe de
t'appartient ainsi à ceux puis que comme
ça campe un peu dans un
dans une région du spectre de la pensée
puis que quelqu'un d'autre
est-elle étiquette ou celle-ci mais là
on peut pas être amis puis on pourra
jamais s'entendre puis
à zip qui dit moi j'ai décidé de me
considérer comme québécois d'abord
puis
ça s'arrête là c'est moi je suis
québécois
si tu es québécois
tu es dans ma gueule
ce je veux dire parce que tu es au
Québec je veux dire toutes sortes de
monde sur le Québec mais il y a une
chose qui nous unit c'est le fait qu'on
est tout québécois
je pense que c'est assez
pour créer un lien assez fort pour nous
unir finalement puis pour que mon cercle
d'empathie que tu sois à l'intérieur de
ça plutôt qu'à l'extérieur puis après
ceux quand tu vois ça de même mais tu
dis tous ces gens là c'est des Québécois
on est tout dans une même gagne mais
après ça les 10 différentes parce qu'au
final c'est des petites souvent des
petites différences là c'est que ton
voisin il est différente toi mais je
veux dire c'est un Québécois aussi puis
il mérite ton respect puis mérite ton
empathie puis
c'est ce moi je trouve que après ça ça
remet les choses en perspective
différemment puis après ça même j'étais
pris des petites notes j'ai pas oublié
tu sais après ça aussi il y a des
différences
je pense que une fois que tu réussis je
pense à
appliquer ça pour le Québec tu peux
l'appliquer pour le moment de l'élargir
puis au final de dire ce qui nous unit
c'est au final l'humanité
en fait toute partie de cette même gagne
prenez tout le je vois dans les grands
principes
[Musique]
on est tout dans ce voyage là ensemble
puis c'est aussi bien essayer de
de le faire ensemble de le faire
ensemble telle élargir à tout le monde
la bienveillance dans le fond c'est un
mot un peu utilisé à toutes les sauces
mais je pense quand même que
quand activement tu essaies d'appliquer
ça mettons la bienveillance à tous
c'est difficile parce que c'est pas tout
le monde qui l'applique puis des fois je
sais c'est chiant parce que
il fait chier mais
si je commence par moi c'est déjà un
chemin de fer puis en espérant que
d'autres qui le font
là je vais sur un autre podcast
un autre truc qui m'avait marqué
avec ça quand on dit élargir ça mettons
à plus large que le Québec à tout le
monde c'est quelque chose que Rio a le
dit quand alors sur
qu'elle a dit on n'a pas de mérite
d'être Québécois ça ça
le fait qu'on est né au Québec qui est
une des sociétés mettons où on vit le
milieu dans le monde le mettons c'est de
la pure chance c'est un peu purger
je suis né ici quelqu'un qui est moins
chanceux qui a des conditions horribles
horribles ou qui des des cartes de la
vie vraiment horrible puis
il y a aucune raison pourquoi que
timeton j'ai comme ça c'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai mérité c'est quelque
chose que j'ai juste été chanceux
je peux juste être empathique je peux
pas je veux dire quelqu'un qui vous
mettons qui voudrait par exemple
émigré ici pour essayer d'atteindre une
meilleure vie maintenant
je peux pas lui fermer la porte
c'est la pression que tu sortes de
d'autres enjeux mais je veux dire
mettons du meilleur humain
qui sont plus dictés par le gouvernement
puis pas la réception des autres
Québécois mettons là
une fois avoir dépassé la logistique de
venir ici ben là il y a aucune raison
je mérite pas plus sûr que lui je disais
moi j'étais chanceux puissant bref
plus de plus je vous souhaite ça entrer
en 2020
de compréhension puis plus de
puis une chose que Joe le grand sage a
dit ce que je joue de la musique pas mal
avec depuis l'été passé
quelque chose quelqu'un fait quelque
chose un peu dommage puis aurait pu être
de sa position il aurait pu être genre
[Musique]
tout le monde a une raison là
puis il est vraiment de ça de même genre
puis moi
tout le monde a un backgroundé
puis des fois quelqu'un peut faire de
quoi que tu juges complètement
tu peux pas comprendre en fait que je
suis complètement WAC ou qui est
complètement off puis peut-être que ça
le lit objectivement mais je veux dire
ça vient quand même de quelque chose de
toute une vie mais c'est drôle que tu
que tu mettes des affaires ensemble
parce que le podcast à dire bon on a
parlé de la gif de Will Smith dans le
podcast addict
a fait une entrevue au Tonight Show avec
Joachim
puis c'est comme son premier retour
de basket
c'était un peu ça qui disait c'est
évidemment ça s'excuse c'est évidemment
il dit genre ça n'a aucun sens versus
puis il dit mais
vous pouvez jamais savoir ce que
quelqu'un vit c'est un bon spin
marketing mettons que tu veux blanchir
ton nom ou un ever mais le message
demeure quand même déjà tu peux pas
savoir ce que quelqu'un vit-il puis
c'était bien semaine de l'autre podcast
que j'écoute qui commente le sport puis
la culture populaire qui a reçu Jimmy
Kemal sur son sur son podcast
pour parler de ça
on va avoir un site down interview avec
Will Smith pidi va avoir un énorme bloc
qu'on sait pas maintenant ils vont une
énorme affaire qui va apprendre mettons
là qu'on a qu'une idée genre qui dit ça
probablement un guest
Christmas éduqué mettons là
c'est le premier à dire c'est le dernier
si tu fais jamais ça genre ça a aucun
rapport à faire ça c'est débile monter
sur siège aux Oscar donne une claque
d'en face du gars qui est là genre ça
par rapport mais j'ai mis que moi le dit
il va avoir un gros chunk de toute cette
histoire là qu'on a aucune idée après ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut tout laisser
passer au contraire ça ça explique ça
excuse pas ça justifie pas c'est ça
permet de peut-être pas genre être
attaché à se faire un tabarnak c'est
comme ok il y a à ce moment là il agit
comme un Decker puis un tabarnak ok mais
attends mais c'est quand même mais c'est
vrai que tout le monde agit enfin
comment il y a juste à cause de quelque
chose
mais on va aller écouter un extrait avec
Adil
moi je pense qu'un bon artiste ou un bon
politicien mais je vais aller avec les
politiciens c'est quelqu'un qui ne veut
pas être élu
c'est pas quelqu'un que toutes ces
actions c'est pour être élu c'est il ne
veut pas être élu il fait exactement ce
qu'il pense qu'il doit faire il y avait
pas la job moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresserait j'ai quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un au pouvoir qui dit guys qui tu
regardes le peuple dans les yeux aux
prochaines élections prenez-en un autre
style mais là c'est moi qui est là puis
je dois faire ce que je pense que la
bonne chose à faire puis je suis pas en
train d'essayer de charmer personne puis
je suis pas en train d'essayer de vous
crouser ou de vous envoyer des chèques
ou des chutes ou des ok j'essaye de
faire la bonne affaire
pour tout le monde puis si vous voulez
pas calissez moi dehors je vais avoir
donné le meilleur de moi-même puis je
dors bien la nuit mais je pense que ça
c'est pas quelque chose qui existe en ce
moment moi je pense que on regarde des
politiciens puis on regarde les artistes
aussi que de plus en plus comme ok le
mot business dans show business il est
rendu en lettre majuscule pile mot chaud
il est rendu il est rendu petit comme ça
c'est vraiment
l'argent
c'est l'argent qui tire la qui tire le
jus c'est correct je comprends ça mais
moi c'est le système dans lequel on est
mais mais
le système dans lequel on est valorise
pas quelque chose dans les gens ont
réellement besoin qui est de
l'authenticité
de du risque
de la solitude c'est comme toutes des
c'est comme c'est le fait c'est le fait
de faire quelque chose puis de se sentir
que tu es pas dans la pote t'es pas à la
mode mais que tu écoutes ton cœur mais
ça tous les humains ont besoin de ça
mon dernier extrait
c'est oui pour le podcast qu'on a fait
avec mais c'est aussi pour l'ensemble de
l'oeuvre l'ensemble de l'oeuvre parce
que c'est probablement notre meilleur
allié notre meilleur allié de 1 de 2
probablement dans mon top 3 des invités
qu'on a eu à plusieurs reprises au sans
fil
de par sa verve et ça ça connaissance du
sujet et c'est Frédéric Gagnon le
podcast qu'on a fait sur les meeters
Américains avec Frédéric Gagnon c'est un
sujet quand même niche tu sais la police
américaine c'est surtout les méthodes je
les ai pas genre l'élection
présidentielle puis la gare la gare
Afghanistan là tu sais c'est vraiment
comme de quoi être plus niche plus
politique plus game politique mettons
mais c'était quand même je trouvais ça
intéressant comme sujet c'est moi qui
l'avait proposé de parler de ça puis
c'était aussi pour en profiter pour
recevoir Frédéric François qui est peu
importe le sujet pour ça ultra
intéressant c'est ça exactement puis
comme le fait aussi moi je fais beaucoup
parler le monde l'aime beaucoup Frédéric
qui vient sur le Podcast puis il est
tellement dans un naturel
comme frappant quand ils parlent le
sujet là qui maîtrise comme le fond de
sa poche il y a rien de la police
américaine qui ne connaît pas dans le
fond puis le fait qu'il connaisse tout
ça il est capable d'expliquer tout dans
l'histoire et dans le présent toutes les
tout ce qui s'est passé il est capable
de leur mettre en perspective historique
avec les autres résultats de médecin
postérieur à ça postérieur antérieur
antérieur à soi postérieur c'est après
c'est ça
mais je trouve c'est tout le temps
vraiment le fun et le faire avec
légèreté aussi pitié
les amateurs de politique américaine il
en mangent une tabarnak derrière les
années dans ton quotidien et des
shootings des des scandales des trumps
des tweets de Trump des allégations
d'inondité c'est genre la politique
américaine indice derrière années ça a
été le plus grand shit show le fait
quelqu'un qui est si ça passion qui suit
ça
c'est quand même c'est mais il y en
parle avec tellement de
tellement encore d'optimistes pour ce
que la l'institution
de la police américaine et que genre
espoir puis je trouve ça vraiment cool à
en parler avec parler de ça parler
n'importe quoi
américaines avec Valérie Baudou
qui qui sommes toutes
ième c'est culturelle t'intéresser à un
sujet puis pas l'aimer un peu
essentiellement nous aussi cette culture
américaine je veux dire on la consomme
quasiment plus que la
on a tous on a tous intérêt à lui mais
oui c'est clairement pays qui est
capable du meilleur
ou si l'ensemble de l'oeuvre parce que
Fred a commencé c'est un bon allié parce
que souvent c'est lui qui nous
recommande des quelques
temps toutes les fois où il y a un
événement international qui
son ordi pour répondre à genre ok
recevez cette personne là avec son avec
son contact puis genre lui s'assurer de
faire déjà le premier contact tu sais
que on écrivait à cette personne là la
personne venait dans le 48 heures
pratiquement au podcast genre bouquet ça
derrière mes notes parce que c'est des
enjeux d'actualité quand même ça
marchait tout le temps c'est tout le
temps un invité vraiment pro qui
connaissait son sujet comme le dos de sa
main c'était c'est ça c'était tout le
temps
merci Fred merci Fred on va aller
écouter un extrait du podcast
j'imagine que c'est ça c'est juste comme
dans le paraître des mails sur Internet
là mais qu'est-ce qui explique ça non
mais juste pour rebondir la souillé
fatigué c'est clair
je la regardais c'est pas de je pourrais
amoureux de Biden tous les présidents
ont cette job là à faire c'est une job
qui est pas facile c'est il faisait
campagne pour les médecins il était en
Pennsylvanie puis essayer d'aider les
candidats candidates démocrate dans les
états clés de l'élection les résultats
tu as même pas encore connu puis lui bah
il partait en Europe pour des réunions
internationales décalage horaire
évidemment qui s'endort dans des
réunions moi je vais en conférence des
fois à Paris je m'endors
on va quasiment essayer de le comme
quelqu'un qui est en perte de faculté
de progression que ça va jusque qui
passe vraiment qu'il y a en perte de ton
ennemi ou juste
dans un centre de soins de longue durée
là
[Rires]
et quand je suis pas médecin mais mais
il a rendu il a rendu ses rapports
médicaux publics si ça vaut ce que ça
vaut tu peux bon peut-être qu'ils
reprennent mandat deuxième avis un
deuxième médecin dirait mais ça va pas
si bien que ça mais les rapports
médicaux sont corrects pour un gars de
son âge tu sais mais c'est sûr qu'il y a
plus il y a plus l'énergie dans le temps
et puis il y a bien il y a pas mal de
démocrates qui disent ils devraient
laisser sa place pour la suite des
choses un mandat c'est assez parce que
là peut-être que ça va bien mais à la
fin de son deuxième mandat il y aurait
quoi 86 ans c'est une bonne différence
en 80 tu glisses une plaque de glace
puis exactement tu casses une ange
ça tient à ça
il y a eu des présidents français qui
avait des des ennuis de santé majeures
c'est Johnson il y en a d'autres mais là
c'est le problème c'est probidden c'est
quand on le voit maintenant on peut pas
dissimuler ça aussi facilement que dans
le temps avec les médias sociaux on
disait tantôt les clips les mimes les
tout le monde a une caméra dans sa poche
puis on peut on peut filmer Biden qui
déboule un escalier déjà vu chuter dans
un escalier donc puis là ça va mais à 86
ans
je sais pas je sais pas à quoi ça
ressemble parce que déjà 74 ans il y a 6
ans Biden avait plus d'énergie quand on
est à 80 puis là il y a eu un sondage je
réponds pas tout à l'heure mais il y a
eu un sondage récent qui était
intéressant ça vaut ce que ça vaut les
sondages j'ai eu des erreurs aussi dans
les sondages en 2022 on prend en parler
mais un sondage qui disait que il y a
une majorité de démocrates
l'Américain vient de majorité aussi
démocrate qui estime que Biden devrait
laisser sa place après un mandat donc
c'est pas juste les adversaires de Biden
qui disent il sera plus capable bientôt
il y a aussi des gens dans le parti qui
disent bon Biden nous a rendu service il
y a battu Trump en 2020 c'est lui qui
apprenait pour battre un par 2020 salut
que ça prenait son en avait parlé la
dernière fois il y avait réussi à aller
chercher la coalition nécessaire pour
gagner la présidentielle
il nous a rendu service mais plusieurs
démocrates le voient un petit peu comme
un président de transition quatre ans
puis après ça on pense à autre chose
parce que de la relève du côté démocrate
mais on reviendra sur les élections 2022
mais ça serait quand même surprenant qui
se représente non
c'est vraiment la question un million de
dollars moi je te dirais que s'il y
avait perdu si les démocrates c'était
fait plantes aux élections 2022 là je
pense que dans le parti là il y a
beaucoup de démocrates qui aurait dit ok
là
c'est pas la solution pour la suite des
choses mais Biden et un des gagnants des
élections 2022 c'est un des présidents
les plus impopulaires de l'histoire
depuis qu'on tient des sondages
là-dessus un des présidents les plus
impopulaires à perdre si peu aux
élections de mi-mandat c'est un peu
comme quand les Canadiens étaient
presque dans le cas puis on fait la
finale la Coupe Stanley
c'était très étonnant et 2022 pour moi
c'est un peu ça avec Biden dit quoi
mais c'est ça qui a dit d'ailleurs au
lendemain desiteuses ce qui a dit c'est
ben voyez il y a vraiment un appétit
pour ce que j'ai proposé qu'est-ce que
j'ai proposé
des investissements dans les
infrastructures de ramener de bons
emplois aux États-Unis tout ça mais ce
que j'ai promis aussi c'est un retour à
la modération
moins de cris moins chicane moins de
base politique moins d'attaques
personnelles les gens sont années de ça
si tu regardes 2022 bah il y a beaucoup
de d'observateurs d'observatrices qui
qui voit ça dans les résultats 2020
c'est ça que je voulais vous parler
aujourd'hui
c'était barbada barbada c'était c'était
quelque chose pour vrai genre c'était
surprenant moi je pensais qu'on allait
parler vraiment de l'ordre du drague en
fait là qui était justement on a parlé
du podcast mais on aurait dû aviser
mieux ça ouais moi je me doutais parce
que l'émission aussi de pour les jeunes
ou qui parle de musique je savais qu'il
était prof de musique aussi donc je me
doutais que puis je voulais en parler
aussi de tes d'enseignements de la
musique mais tout ça mais si je pensais
pas que cette personne là était
[Musique]
dans ma famille ça a été un podcast
marquant un gros moi j'ai une sœur qui
est enseignante puis elle a écouté ce
podcast là puis elle disait j'étais
emballé par son discours j'étais le oui
c'est vrai que ça marche pas le système
à cause de ça puis il tient c'était des
bons points tout le temps puis c'était
curieux aussi ce podcast parce que on a
tellement essentiellement pas parler de
drague dans le fond un petit peu un
petit peu à la fin que il y a du monde
qui m'ont dit par la suite genre ah mais
on mentionne je pense que barbada a dit
elle est là là allez sur Youtube pour
voir parce que je me suis pas habillé de
même pour rien parce que c'est comme
c'est en audio
qui parle
tellement d'assurance puis genre
tellement de passion puis de connais
connaissance que c'est ça qui est tout
que tu oublies que selectan audio
mais oui c'est ça
que tu réalises à quel point je trouve
le système d'éducation comme ça ça fait
plus de sens le genre c'est vraiment
dysfonctionnel c'est puis moi
ce que ça m'a fait penser je sais pas si
je l'avais déjà dit le même mot dans le
fond qu'acheter université moi j'ai fait
mes études en musique puis j'avais un de
mes amis un moment donné que ça job en
même temps en même temps on est à
l'école c'était il y avait commencé à
faire des remplacements en musique
primaire je pense puis en fait le gars
il y avait pas une formation en
enseignement de la musique il y avait
vraiment juste comme une formation
musique comme moi dans le fond là
il manque tellement de staff tu sais que
là il s'est ramassé à enseigner la
musique puis non seulement il s'est
ramassé enseigné la musique mais c'est
ramasser enseigner l'éthique genre puis
comme donner des cours des dieux et de
remplacer dans plein de matière puis le
gars il y a aucune formation là-dedans
genre il y a aucune formation en
enseignement tout court puis au final il
était rendu quasiment temps plein juste
à remplacer partout on a eu des fois au
secondaire des profs si je me rappelle à
un moment donné je me rappelle que Kino
notre prof de maths ont l'air 2
enseigner les tiques pendant genre
ça s'appelait je sais pas quand c'est
quoi le nom exact de ce cours-là mais ça
fait que les Marseillais les maths puis
genre comment mettre un condom
mais aussi probablement que ce gars là
il y avait quand même une formation de
profiter mais je me suis pas soutien
mais on a eu un prof un remplaçant en
maths
je travaillais dans le milieu
pharmaceutique là mais là je faisais
bien de l'argent mais peut-être en place
je peux faire maintenant ce qui
m'intéresse maintenant ce qui
t'intéresse c'est quoi venir remplacer
en maths 4 36 puis vient nous enseigner
mais genre il est tellement genre pas
politique non genre il nous dit
d'affaires qui devrait pas dire des kits
de 15 ans qui avait appris ce qui nous
enseignait la veille j'aurais vu dans le
plan de cours ouais non c'est vrai ça
faut que je la prenne puis là il y a
rien il y a réviser il y a sorti avec
des maths fortes gentil c'est université
mais genre ça puis là y arriver genre il
y avait ce qu'il est drôle montrer des
photos de sa blonde
ça c'est après
on a 15 ans c'est passé
[Rires]
ça c'est juste en terme de staff mais
après ça c'est tout tout le cursus c'est
tout ce que tu apprends comme tel puis
barbada c'est ça qui est qui avait qui
est intéressant je trouve de ce qu'elle
a mis dans cette podcast là c'est que il
y a des affaires qui il y a fallu
qu'elle amène carrément parce que
pour elle c'était juste important en
fait de d'enseigner ça nos enfants c'est
parce que la réalité puis c'est vrai
c'est que il y a beaucoup de stocks
quand tu apprends à l'école que tu t'en
serviras pas pour de vraies puis on
apprend pas à vivre comme tel puis je me
rappelle que elle ce qu'elle disait
c'est que dans le plan de cours il y a
comme une partie qui est juste écrit
socialisé c'est à l'école Jean tu
apprends que ma socialiser puis c'est
super large ça en fait cette catégorie
là mais c'est là-dedans que genre tu
rentres les skills un peu de justement
vivre et puis
c'est ça puis en tout cas bref je
trouvais ça super super pertinent super
intéressant puis je trouve ça ça donne
ça donne des bonnes idées moi si j'étais
un prof j'écoutais ça en fait genre pour
vrai je m'arrangerai le peu comme
essayer de faire une place pour ce genre
d'enseignement là dans mon plan de
course moi je pense moi je vais te semis
te réfuter parce que je pense pas
je pense que mettons ce qu'on apprend à
l'école et pour la grande majorité
mettons importants puis je pense que
mettons la plupart du monde dans les
écoles c'est du monde qui crissement
dévoué qui font genre vraiment du mieux
qui peuvent je pense que en fait je
pense que le problème c'est que on
devrait avoir un budget probablement
genre deux fois plus élevé pour
l'éducation qu'est-ce qu'on a mis en ce
moment puis
parce que mettons là ce qui arrive c'est
que
les profs ils peuvent même avec ta bonne
volonté du monde
aussi que le
système est faite pour c'est pas vrai
que tout le monde peut apprendre la même
façon mais c'est pour ça que c'est 25
personnes dans une classe c'est sûr que
le temps
qui ont des rides différents qui ont des
méthodes d'apprentissage différents qui
ont qui
vont en avoir plein puis tu auras pas le
temps assez de soit du personnel
qualifié personnalisé ou soit juste
avoir moins de monde dans les classes
pour pouvoir avoir plus de temps avec
chacun des élèves
moi je pense que c'est ça c'est que là
on met tout le monde dans un même moule
parce que on n'a pas les ressources pour
comme
s'adapter aux spécificités de chacun
pour ça je pense pas non plus que
mettons cette transaction dans une
classe qu'on est les 30 complètement
genre
complément différents je pense que je
pense que quand même probablement une
genre de nom puis après ça c'est
toujours du monde à l'extérieur de ça
c'est les autres qu'il faut aller
chercher people mais c'est ça mais je
pense que je pense que ça juste pas de
bon sens comme les profs qui ont à faire
avec les moyens qui ont avec le nombre
d'élèves qui ont avec les c'est fou le
titre puis on leur demande de faire en
fait l'impossible et puis souvent ils
arrivent en plus parce qu'ils
travaillent trois fois plus fort qui
qu'on leur demande finalement
cette année on a aussi reçu le ministre
de l'économie de la ministre des
Finances sur le Podcast puis quelque
chose qui nous disait c'est que 60% du
budget qui va en santé fait que tant
qu'on est avec ce problème là
[Musique]
c'est qu'on peut pas non plus rajouter
tant que ça des affaires
de cuisine ou des cours à un moment
donné c'est
on a déjà tu sais parce que je suis
d'accord avec toi pour dire que mettons
quand même important d'avoir des cours
de maths puis des cours de science puis
genre parce que je veux pas ça forme un
raisonnement pareil
même si tu t'en sors pas plus tard ça
reste que c'est c'est fou l'important
pour ton développement mais cela dit tu
sais c'est que il y a des affaires qui
sont aussi fulls importants qu'on voit
pas du tout puis si ça pour moi je
trouve que c'est aussi vraiment
important de le voir à l'école parce que
sinon il y a beaucoup de monde qu'il
voit juste jamais mais on peut pas la
réalité c'est qu'on peut pas l'ajouter
avec ce que des gens en ce moment c'est
il faut qu'on enlève une partie pour
être capable d'en rajouter un autre mais
je pense aussi il faut ce questionner
sur c'est quoi le rôle c'est quoi le qui
la part du
c'est quoi qui t'as l'école d'enseigner
c'est quoi qui est au courant parce
qu'il y a des choses qui tentent
le système a été conçu comprenait pour
acquis que ce c'était l'éducation des
parents qui était prise en charge puis
peut-être que ça se fait plus peut-être
que ça s'est perdu peut-être que ça n'a
jamais été je sais pas mais je pense
qu'il y a aussi une partie de
l'éducation de l'enfant qui qui vient
n'est pas grave de former justement
quelqu'un qui je veux dire fonctionnel
en société puis petit point de vue des
valeurs des points de vue de de se
débrouiller puis point de vue d'avoir
des conversations sur justement aussi
les sujets comme plus plus plat à avoir
avec ton enfant comme le consentement
puisse faire le
je pense les parents je veux dire ça
fait partie du rôle ouais je suis
d'accord mais c'est ce qui est triste
aussi c'est que les parents sont pas
plus outillés souvent en fait ce genre
d'affaires là c'est en plus ça fait
dès le consentement maintenant c'est fou
l'important mais ça reste que
nos enfants
[Musique]
que je considère que c'est quand même
important c'est d'encadrer ce genre
d'enseignement là justement pour parce
que c'est les enseignements qui sont
fous l'important c'est je trouve que ça
ça peut si ça passe par le système
d'éducation c'est un petit peu plus que
mais uniforme comme Jean d'enseignement
podcast
on va mettre un extrait
primaire le 11 ans à peu près le
primaire dépendamment
toutes tes fondations à stage
honnêtement
parce que
ils disent que souvent comme un groupe
de personnes le quotient intellectuel
des enfants de 12 ans puis honnêtement
quand il les regarde interagir un groupe
de personnes qui a pas de structure
nécessairement puis tu réalises
qu'effectivement c'est des enfants de 12
ans
tu dis ça c'est le portrait de notre
future génération pas mal là oui
évidemment au secondaire
mais ce qu'ils ont acquis comme valeur
puis comme base comme fondation c'est à
la fin du primaire que c'est là il y a
des choses qui peuvent changer mais ça
prend beaucoup de choses pour changer
des choses parce que là ça a été ancré
fait que tu les habitudes tôt à être
ouvert à la différence avec toutes ces
valeurs là
ça se passe pas au secondaire ça se
passe au primaire puis moi je leur ai
parlé dans certaines mes copies c'est un
des gros avantages avoir des cours d'art
moi je suis j'appelle tout ça des cours
d'art plus que des cours de musique
c'est de pouvoir parler de plein de
sujets qui sont même un peu
avant-gardiste ou en côté de d'amener
d'utiliser l'or pour amener plein de
sujets puis moi je leur ai parlé
d'environnement mais je leur ai parlé
aussi d'alcool dans un de mes projets
qu'on a fait
amener je voulais résume mais bref on
avait un sujet où on navigue à travers
les couleurs
puis quand on était rendu dans le bloc
jaune qui était le bloc du plaisir dans
l'histoire qu'on faisait dans le
spectacle qu'on montait ben justement je
parlais du plaisir puis comment on en
arrive à avoir du plaisir on peut avoir
du plaisir dans la vie de tous les jours
mais des gens qui parfois c'est
utilisent des substances pour avoir du
plaisir j'ai pas mentionné les drogues
mais j'ai parlé de l'alcool qu'est-ce
que ça fait l'alcool ben c'est que ça te
crée un faux plaisir c'est que ton
balancier là qui va de gauche à droite
du plaisir au moins plaisir ou tu sais
qui continuellement balance comme ça là
tu vas artificiellement tirer du côté
plaisir puis il va falloir que tu larges
on aurait dit tu peux pas continuer à
boire tout le temps il faut que tu
arrêtes faut que tu larges faut que tu
sois prêt à ce qu'il revienne l'autre
côté mais des gens qui sont pas prêts
bref je vous le résume super vite mais
si je parle puis j'ai jamais dans ce
cours-là jamais eu l'attention des
élèves autant alors qu'il y a plein de
parents qui peut-être écoutent en ce
moment même qui disent mais non mais on
peut pas parler à des enfants de 11 ans
12 ans d'alcool oui mais oui mais avec
des mots enfin c'est la même chose avec
la sexualité aussi j'avais beaucoup de
parents qui sont réticents à parler de
sexualité mais ta sexualité d'adulte qui
a vécu toutes les choses que tu as
vécues ça c'est ta vision la sexualité
replace-toi comme un enfant de 12 ans ou
de 11 ans ou de 10 ans c'est quoi sa
sexualité à lui c'est pas genre tu sais
un peu tu comprends c'est pas faire des
félins
[Rires]
ça prenne pour en parler
mais bref c'est pas ça la parler de
sexualité à un jeune parler de sexualité
un jeune c'est parler d'acceptation
parler de compréhension de parler de
dire à 11 ans le tendresse le dos de ta
mère en t'imaginant que c'est ton ami
que tu connais petit fermant les yeux
parce que jamais connu ça embrasser
quelqu'un c'est ça là la sexualité pour
un jeune de 12 ans ça se passe pas
nécessairement avoir des culottes ça se
passe beaucoup dans la tête avec parlons
de parlons de consentement à ces jeunes
là c'est là que ça commence tu sais on
est bien c'est quoi ton deuxième
mon deuxième c'était 1000 non mais
les deux que tu as nommés mettons
c'était dans ma liste tu m'as dit que
c'était chouette
première podcast que le podcast avec le
plus grosses que des côtes de 2022
je pense que
mais je pense que c'est une histoire qui
frappe imaginaire
qui vraiment incroyable parce que parce
que l'histoire c'est
quand que c'était arrivé on s'en
rappelle encore tu sais en tout cas moi
je veux parler pour moi parce que je
sais pas pour d'autres mais moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'avait vraiment
frappé tu sais parce que c'était en
plein au moment où est-ce que je
commençais personnellement avoir la
réflexion sur genre le paraître puis les
réseaux sociaux puis l'influence puis
genre je commençais à me dire et il y a
quelque chose là qui commence à chier là
dans Comment on vit le en ce moment là
ça arrive puis là c'était comme le
comble c'était comme le comble de
l'histoire c'est genre en plus
évidemment en parlant mais non on s'est
rendu compte que c'était pas exactement
ça qui avait des trous qui se tapaient
perdus dans dans le clickbait tout ce
qui est encore un problème en soi mais
est-ce que c'est à sortais c'était comme
deux jeunes influenceuses décident de
partir en voyage avec un sugar daddy
pour avoir des photos de voyage puis
avoir des likes sur Instagram
de l'histoire l'espèce de culmination de
la culture des lacs
ça c'est ce qu'on s'est fait de projeter
le grandement puis j'avais apprécié
j'avais arrêté de tuer je savais pas que
c'était 50 prison je savais pas toutes
ces affaires là mais finalement quand
après ça moi je l'avais réécouté sur le
Podcast de tienne boulet
mais puis là j'avais fait un crissement
le fait sans connaître notre podcast
mais essentiellement avec en tête le
même genre de jeu de mots que nous on
avait le qui était de combiné un peu la
on enlève les filtres de commerce de la
culture du web puis on fait un peu ce
qu'on veut
que la disait un peu la même façon mais
puis après ça j'ai vu que l'autre fait
avec qui était alone série sur crève
voulez pas être le tir déjà tu sors au
Sous-Bois un soir il va avoir du monde
comme ça qui recherche la tension qui
aime ça avoir les regards sur elle puis
qui vont ils vont prendre des mauvaises
décisions liées à ça il y en a plein il
y a du monde plus influençable que
d'autres aussi et puis quand tu traînes
dans les bars comme tel genre tu sais
c'est un enfant que j'avais vu dans le
documentaire justement mais il y a du
monde qui sont là pour spotter déjà
c'est qui genre les les sites parfaites
pour faire ce genre d'affaires là tu
sais puis qui ils te spote longtemps en
avance puis de travail longtemps en
avance tu peux jamais juger les gens qui
a un affaire qui arrive devant moi c'est
ça que je retiens au final c'est que
premièrement tu as pas son background
puis deuxièmement c'est si tu sais pas
tout ce qui s'est passé avant genre la
démarche avant pour qu'elle accepte
finalement de s'embarquer dans un
affaire on disait de joie tantôt tout le
monde agit d'une façon à cause de à
cause de quelque chose qui est dans leur
vie mais on y parlait moi j'ai le même
feeling que toi il parlait c'est quand
même Chris genre
on n'est pas si différents
[Musique]
du vert de trop quand tu prends ton
short tu devrais peut-être pas le
prendre
ça peut partir vite en culotte quand tu
vas le mauvaise décision là tu essaie
d'en prendre le moins possible dans ta
vie mais genre ça peut vite partir en
cucul
je me rappelle pas si c'est dans ce
podcast là sans fil parce que maintenant
intervenu maintenant à rejeter un
podcast avec sa mère je me rappelle plus
c'est
puis je me rappelle plus si c'était dans
ce podcast là ou dans son filtre mais
elle parlait de 4 à chercher justement
un avocate là pour un avocat pour le
pour la défendre tu sais
puis sa mère qui cherchait dans le fond
puis c'était bien important pour sa mère
de trouver quelqu'un qui comprenait cet
aspect là humain gentil parce que
c'était un cas qui était super médiatisé
que c'était vraiment comme un gros coup
le type pour un avocat d'avoir cette
colle aussi
beaucoup pour justement comprendre que
c'est vraiment genre une fille de 20 ans
genre que c'est fait embarquer dans un
affaire genre c'était vraiment vraiment
important pour elle tu sais puis c'est
ça puis l'autre à faire aussi qu'il
m'avait marqué c'est à quel point genre
les gardes genre les gardes de prison
genre sont ils étaient contents
il y a plusieurs prisons maintenant il y
a plusieurs types de prison puis le
probablement que les gars qui qui tuent
genre de sang-froid à ma répétitions qui
se battent dans prison elle est en
prison même ça me surprendrait qu'à
foutu la marde ou qui a voulu leur faire
chier ou genre tu prends son trou même
puis tu sais les gardes il voit bien
même que c'est une adolescente
ça doit tellement être long même
c'est comme si étant genre de
de tout quasiment végétatif de genre sa
petite routine puis genre probablement
dépressif puis genre mais tu sais que
je pense à s'élever mais dans cette
heure qu'à compter là il y avait des
trucs qui il y avait des activités qui
mettons à travailler il y avait mangé
tout c'était comme à 3h quelque chose
qui était dans sa cellule bon et à clé
jusqu'à ce qu'on a même atteint de 3
heures tu es comme tu tournes en rond
dans une coupe de pieds carrés puis de
titre juste rester chez vous genre sans
sortir
je voulais juste pas sortir de la Villa
puis après trois mois je vais me coller
ça à tête dans le mur
on avait des fois de la bière genre
manger gonflé on peut faire ce qu'on
voulait mais on peut juste pas sortir
même je voulais me casser la tête dans
un cinquant mais 25 ans en prison en
prison dans votre sens mais c'est fou
mais du coup c'est ça c'est tellement je
pense que tu es une des raisons du
succès populaire de ce podcast là c'est
que
ces histoires là puis savoir comment ça
se passe en prison savoir comment
comment s'est rendu là
comment car c'est fait de pognit tu es
toute seule il y en a jamais de
curiosité pour communiquer de comprendre
comment comment tu t'arrives à ça
comment tu vis à travers ça comment tu
passes à autre chose puisqu'on continue
ta vie normale c'est tout ça et tout ça
et super c'est super intrigante et puis
mais intéressant
aujourd'hui ce qu'a fait c'est qu'il se
mâle c'est parce que maintenant je veux
dire à part à d'autres jeunes Mélina qui
pourrait très bien faire les mêmes
erreur parce que comme tu dis il y en a
plein
c'est comme
moi j'ai fait une erreur je peux m'avoir
décision j'ai payé en esti genre je
voulais pas puis je pense que quelqu'un
qui écoute le podcast qui pourrait être
un genre de quelqu'un qui pourrait
prendre ce genre de trajectoire là je
pense que ça peut t'aider à y penser
deux fois à mettre
extrait moi je suis vraiment intrigué
par
comment c'était les cinq années que tu
as passé en prison
qui t'accrochait genre tu avais-tu
mettons quelque chose justement qui
étudie à chaque jour je vais essayer un
genre de but un genre de thé justement
de quelque chose que tu peux progresser
ou bien c'était vraiment juste cinq ans
de comme on va animation
je l'ai dit souvent mais on va aller
plus en profondeur que ça mais en gros
ma famille ma famille c'était sur quoi
je m'accrochais à 100% ok
j'ai dit souvent aussi je savais pas eu
ma famille certains que je serai pas ici
aujourd'hui puis je dis pas ça pour être
dramatique le message je l'aurais pas
été capable
mais sinon
mettons la première année j'ai trouvé
vraiment Rohff parce que justement je
savais pas quand est-ce que je retourne
chez nous j'étais avec du monde que
j'arrivais pas à comprendre où c'était
pas j'avais dit j'avais pas rien qui me
rappelait chez nous c'était juste toute
l'inconnu c'était pas mon langage
et puis je me suis comme tournée vers la
bouffe puis j'ai pris j'en ai une
vingtaine de livres la première année
puis j'ai tout un ticket quelqu'un que
j'ai eu des troubles de poids et puis
être un petit peu plus charnue ça moi ça
je suis pas heureuse dans mon corps
j'étais pas grosse là mais moi il y a un
certain poids que je sais que je suis
confortable puis je passerai pas à si
j'ai des troubles alimentaires je lui ai
expliqué dans le livre ça me ramènera
pas vers ça que je fais attention encore
aujourd'hui et
mais mais à part ma famille je pense que
le fait que j'ai lu quand même beaucoup
de livres c'est faut que tu dises ok tu
es ta même place à toutes les autres tu
te réveilles à mémoire à tous les jours
tu manges en mémoire à tous les jours tu
vas travailler en mémoire tous les jours
tu appelles ta famille à 20h c'est
tellement routinier
que c'est comme si ton cerveau il
devient un peu engourdi un moment donné
jusqu'à tant qu'il y a un changement
j'ai changé de prison 4 fois que c'était
de recommencer à zéro à quatre fois puis
j'avais donc du monde qui m'aimait pas à
cause de ce que j'ai l'air puis le monde
déjà jaloux puis il y avait ça doit être
particulièrement
toutes les asiatiques vont sortir
ensemble elle est latino mais c'est pas
c'est pas comme d'un film comme il y a
personne qui servir de côté là c'est
correct c'est juste que tu te mêles pas
trop moi je m'entendais super bien avec
les Vietnamiens je sais pas pourquoi
j'adore vraiment leur mentalité puis aux
autres croit beaucoup en Bouddha puis
c'est vraiment une belle religion en
tout cas
j'ai créé un peu le groupe de sportifs
si tu veux j'avais comme il y avait eu
un espèce de concours de big is looser
entre belenfant les officiers avait mis
ça en place parce que les femmes et les
hommes mettent quand il y a besoin
d'extérioriser mais il s'entraînait puis
aux autres il y avait des jeunes mais
nous les filles ils mangent
95% de la population en prison sortait
avec un une moyenne de 30 livres de
surplus de poids après en sortant dans
le fond
ça qui avait mis ça en place puis moi
j'ai travaillé dans un gym avant tout
cela il y a très longtemps j'ai déjà
fait des diades puis tout ça enfin les
filles moi j'avais commencé à
m'entraîner puis à courir puis à faire
comme des workouts
se joindre à moi puis à me demander
quand le bébé est sorti mais les filles
étaient quand même
comme comment on fait tout ce genre
celles qui parlent le plus de poids en
le faisant bien aller recevoir genre un
paquet de de Heart work il y avait quand
même des pinceaux puis la peinture mais
je pense que les filles elles faisaient
plus pour la compétition dans le sens
que c'était un Outlook compétition mais
mais c'est pas pour la faire plus pour
moi
j'ai réussi quand même à c'est ça je
m'accrochais à ça aussi je me disais
j'ai pas grand chose mais au moins j'ai
du monde que je peux aider ici c'est
peut-être des amis pareil au travers de
tout ça
j'ai peut-être gardé contact avec deux
personnes depuis que je parle encore
aujourd'hui et on est de retour
alors c'était bac c'était les choix des
nikkys
alors merci d'avoir été là jusqu'au bout
avec nous ouais
[Musique]
c'est ça je vous souhaite en 2000 je me
suis fait donner un souhait ok pour 2023
tout ce que tu veux je te souhaite du
bonheur de la santé puis lorsque je me
suis fait dire si je te souhaite
de recevoir ce que tu vas recevoir mais
d'en faire le mieux que tu peux avec ce
quitter
[Musique]
aux affaires que tu vas pas recevoir de
vivre ce que tu as à vivre mais sortir
le mieux possible il va arriver ce qui
fait arriver fais juste en tirer le plus
de positions
[Musique]
bonne année bonne année à bientôt